on sera tous bienvenue en point de vue
l'émission de décryptage et surtout des
changes d'opinion de préférence
contradictoires sur l'actualité je vous
propose de découvrir le sommaire de
notre émission nous allons commencer par
revenir sur la facture un peu ça l'est
peut-être pour le contribuable du retour
du premier ministre il revenait de
nouvelle calédonie il a pris un avion à
tokyo plus tôt il en a loué un et ça a
coûté 350 mille euros est ce que le
premier ministre dépense trop nous
demanderons à nos invités leurs points
de vue sur ce sujet nous reviendrons
aussi sur ce qui est sans doute la
première grande victoire politique d'une
halte ruff
le vote par le sénat de sa réforme
fiscale est ce que le vent est en train
de tourner pour un président qu'on dise
est tellement affaiblie
nous parlerons aussi de des réactions un
peu un peu vive des députés de la
république en marche face au projet de
loi qui s'annonce préparé par le
ministre de l'intérieur sur le droit
d'asile et surtout sur la lutte contre
les immigrés clandestins
et puis nous parlerons aussi du soutien
apporté par charlie hebdo et en
l'occurrence par son rédacteur en chef
friis atex texte vous vous en souvenez
peut-être cet animateur de télévision
qui a été renvoyé de france 2 pour une
blague jugée probablement à juste titre
comme étant lourde et sexiste bonsoir à
nos quatre invités quatre journalistes
de très haut niveau qui nous ont fait le
plaisir de nous rejoindre cet aprem en
justice guillaume demont jour vous êtes
co reporter au figaro magazine bonsoir
philip earl vous diriger la rédaction
anglaise de radio france internationale
rfi et vous êtes de nationalité
britannique bonsoir lexsi la cour en
soir guillaume directeur délégué de la
rédaction de l'express contributeurs de
la revue la règle du jeu est ce que
votre dernier livre est déjà en
librairie
génisses r mais non vous avez le premier
à faire du teasing c'est super sympa
alors bientôt un livre d'alexis la croix
sur la permanence et même si elle est
évolutif dans sa forme de
l'antisémitisme en france
bonsoir renaud girard beaucoup vous êtes
le chroniqueur international du figaro
nous retrouvons chaque mardi matin dans
notre quotidien préféré vos chroniques
vous est aussi l'auteur d'un livre qui
lui est sorti
quel diplomatie pour la france prendre
les réalités telles qu'elles sont aux
éditions
du cerf parlons si vous le voulez bien
de la facture du dernier voyage du
premier ministre qui était donc parti en
nouvelle calédonie qui étaient rentrés
par un avion de l'état mais à tokyo le
premier ministre et son équipe change
d'avion pour revenir plus vite à paris
et dans des conditions plus confortables
en louant un aéronef facture pour l'état
français
trois cent cinquante mille euros est-ce
que c'est trop est-ce que c'est excessif
le premier ministre il assume cette
dépense il dit quand on occupe les
fonctions que j'ai et bien oui ça coûte
cher et il n'a d'ailleurs pas hésité en
donner d'autres exemples ce matin chez
nos confrères d'rtl
regardez ce matin vous m'avez invité
pour venir sur rtl si vous aviez invité
edouard philippe
je serais venu en métro ça m'aurait
coûté un euro 90 ou deux euros si
j'étais venue en bus ou éventuellement
j'aurais pris taxi j'aurais payé mon
taxi et vous êtes invité le premier
ministre et vous avez peut-être vu quand
je suis arrivé devant les studios de rtl
que je suis arrivé avec quatre véhicules
avec des motards avec plus de 15
personnes avec un médecin madame
martichoux qui me suit en permanence et
un transmetteur de l'armée qui me suit
en permanence parce que c'est le régime
qui est donnée au premier ministre
d'être systématiquement mesure de réagir
et d'avoir sa cousine notablement cher
philippe top questions très directes est
ce que le premier ministre de la france
dépense trop dans ce cas précis oui le
petit voyage à lloret cas du voyage en
nouvelle calédonie où le k2
son ensemble mais ce cas de nouvelle
calédonie il y à il ya deux mesures le
mesure qu'il a le droit de dépenser et
350 miro ou une grosse somme pour revenu
en france pour assister un conseil de
ministres ou réunion de tels des sauces
là je veux bien les moyens existent il a
le droit de conserver le problème c'est
que c'est l'image qui complètement et
qu'on en ait et l'image en premier
ministre qui commence par dire il faut
qu'on fasse des économies partout les
caisses de l'état sont pour ainsi dire
vides et qui dépensent 60 50 mille euros
ça faisait ça ne passe pas un prêt
commun des mortels qui se serrent la
ceinture qui est pas l'enjoint 10 mai
comme ça se paye que il peut dire ok il
lui revient d'urgence de nouvelle
calédonie je ne peux pas prendre un
avion militaire parce que c'est
inconfortable jeune femme allongée
je suis désolé ça ne passe pas et je
peux vous dire une chose qu'ici c'était
en grande bretagne cette histoire auprès
d'un ministre pour un ministre n'importe
quel personnage important dans le
gouvernement
ça ne passera pas parce que une fois que
la presse tabloïd saisi d'une affaire
pareille la personne et est mort et est
politiquement mort et sera obligé à mon
avis de jetter l'épongé
donc c'est un calcul à mauvais calcul et
ça me laisse l'impression toujours que
quand on est pas il le ministre n'est
pas un homme est ministre on dit tous
vos une chose et une fois qu'on devient
milices du premier ministre on se dit
après bomba j'oublie tout cela j'ai le
droit je m'en sers et je pense pas à
tous les gens autour de moi qui m'ont
mis là où je suis et pour moi c'est
exactement dans ce cas là contre eu avec
l oif et libre je suis désolé de le dire
je regrette pour lui qu'il est dans
cette situation mais c'est comme ça que
je le prends moi je vous avez suivi
beaucoup de voyages de ministres comme
journaliste est ce que vous êtes choqués
par cette cette facture ou est-ce que tu
inévitable et qu'il était normal que le
premier ministre vienne dans des
conditions un peu plus confortable et un
peu plus rapide en france plutôt que de
prendre l'avion de l'armée puisque comme
claudel rue nous le rappelle il y avait
un avion de l'armée déjà affrété pour
lui donc il n'était pas nécessaire de
changer sous prétexte de gagner du temps
y être plus à l'aise moi je crois que
d'abord ils étaient 60 dans cet avion
donc 350000 / 60 ça fait à peu près 6000
par personne quand vous regardez leur
france tokyo paris les en première à peu
près autour de 4000 ou 5000 euros et
parfois même 8000 euros donc on est dans
une proportion il a dû faire son calcul
l'audience ça sera encore acceptée par
l'opinion mais je crois que c'est moi la
grandeur du montant de cette dépense qui
choque les français que la petitesse des
dépensiers faire s'il est pas grave de
justifier que ces quatre jours en
nouvelle calédonie ont été importants où
il a travaillé pour la france est ce que
cette délégation de 60 personnes étaient
justifiées pour quatre jours là bas
parce que c'est pas ça que ça ne s'est
pas seulement le transport qui est cher
mais c'est aussi le séjour de toutes ces
personnes est ce que ces 60 personnes
étaient dans la délégation des amis des
influents des des journalistes à draguer
tout ça a mûri ce que c'étaient des
hommes déjà d'entreprise des voiliers
une espèce de voilà c'est moi c'est ça
qui m'intriguait ce que est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on a les moyens en tant
que puissance moyenne ou relative de
d'assumer ce train de vie qui est encore
lié à celui d'une grande puissance
c'était ça promet si la croatie que
comme les français ne voient pas
l'utilité de l'action publique il la
trouve forcément trop cher je suis
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
guyonne par trop commun parce que c'est
de débattre
je suis d'accord non mais je suis
d'accord qu'il est difficile pour le
téléspectateur moyen qui est un citoyen
qui doit qui mérite notre respect il lui
est difficile de se représenter ce qu'a
pu faire le premier ministre pendant
quatre jours sur le caillou comme on dit
pour désigner la nouvelle calédonie dans
un processus d'ailleurs lancé par
l'exécutif actuel par philippe mais
aussi par macron pour permettre que il
ya une autodétermination des calédoniens
sur le statut à venir l'avenir de l'île
alors effectivement il est allé donc
avec une délégation importante
je suis d'accord avec dionne il faut se
demander qui étaient les personnes qui
l'accompagnaient est-ce que ça n'était
qu'une sorte de noria de flatteurs ou
est-ce que c'était des gens qui peuvent
vraiment servir au développement futur
de la calédonie ça c'est une vraie
question
mais en revanche je suis malheureusement
en désaccord complet avec la vision que
vous avez j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
votre travail et pour vos témoignages
mais je pense que ça vous voyez vous
référer par exemple à la mauvaise image
que philippe
à voir s'il devait tomber sous le coup
des tabloïds anglais s'est pas
franchement c'est pas le meilleur du
modèle anglo saxon ces tragédies pas
c'est un non mais non j'ai déjà eu à y
voilà j'aime bien bouger bien compris
mais c'est traque des responsables
publics
même les plus éminents auxquels sont
soumis dans les tabloïds anglo-saxons la
plupart des hommes politiques de qualité
c'est affreux et donc je ne suis pas le
défenseur attitré d'edouard philippe
mais je pense effectivement comme
guyonne l'a dit que quand on divise la
somme par les soixante personnes de la
délégation
au fond c'est un billet assez normal de
business class pour un aller-retour
nouméa en gros ça doit être à peu près
les mêmes chiffres
donc rien de la d'extraordinaire et je
pense une deuxième chose qui n'est pas
dite et qui est dit par exemple par
quelqu'un qui n'est pas suspect d'avoir
particulièrement besoin d'entrer dans la
cour d'edouard philippe c'est manuel
valls
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait valser là il ya
quelques heures il a fait un trou et en
disant je sais par expérience moi qui
suis allé aussi que les voyages en
calédonie avec des délégations ça coûte
très cher donc voilà il faut raison
garder je crois qu'il doit philippe n'a
commis aucune faute même pas une faute
par rapport à son image et c'est le
populisme ambiant qui nous défendent le
regard sur ce type de voyage pas vous
dire en tout cas c'est que depuis que
cette émission existe point de vue je
n'ai jamais vu autant de réactions parce
que vous savez que sur twitter les lélés
ceux qui nous regardent et sur
lefigaro.fr peuvent commenter en direct
autant de réactions sur un sujet je peux
pas les je peux pas les citer toutes il
ya martine villemin qui nous diront des
mois la csg je suis une retraités aisés
à 1300 euros sont que allusion
évidemment ironique au à l'augmentation
de la csg pour tous les retraités qui
touchent plus que ça alors y'a chloé qui
dit non je ne trouve pas que le voyage
du premier ministre soit choquant mais
tous les autres
francis berger le fait qu'il est c'est
ta conscience vis-à-vis de l'argent du
contribuable est inacceptable albert
bastarache oui ce voyage est choquant
yolande et cet avion est devenue vide
coline meissonnier qui nous dit ce
gouvernement un train de vie royal
patricia vouriot qui nous dit pourquoi
une si grande délégation c'est juste une
honte
et j'arrête là pardon pour les autres
j'ai un autre que john lycée joie juste
un mot il n'est pas allé en vacances
oui il débat il n'est pas les grands aux
annonces et c'est même pas la
configuration qui s'était présentée
lorsque l'ancien premier ministre valls
avait emmené ses deux fils dans le cadre
d'un voyage où il allait voir platini il
avait emmené ses deux fils voir un match
de l'euroligue
il lui avait été fait reproche d'avoir
utilisé un avion de la république
d'ailleurs c'était en gens parce que ils
allaient travailler en réalité lui là
ils n'allaient pas s' amuser mais nous
et ce n'est même pas cette configuration
nouvelle vie d'ailleurs mettre
franchement il ya non mais enfin fini
avec les motos non mais moi la pression
on à la région rhône de fleurs et là j
ai évidemment si yo yo sérieusement on a
l'impression depuis hier soir que
monsieur edouard philippe est parti avec
femme et enfants au soleil pendant
quinze jours se donnerait la pilule aux
frais du contribuable c'est pas du tout
le cas faut se calmer les années alors
qu'elle met alors d'intérieur caniveau
mais pas trop parce que le débat est
vivant et moi j'adore ça
donc je rappelle deux choses d'abord que
vous sur twitter vous pouvez répondre à
cette question edouard philippe
dépense-t-il trop hashtag figaro light
hashtag point de vue nous allons
entendre le point de vue de vaugirard
mais pas avant d'en avoir entendu un
autre
si vous êtes d'accord pour passer un
accord quelques instants chez renault
damien abad de le vice président des
républicains était ce matin sur ses news
et le moins qu'on puisse dire est que
lui aussi était plutôt sévère c'est le
symbole de la déconnexion du pouvoir
avec les français aujourd'hui beaucoup
de français vont partir en vacances ils
attendent leurs horaires du vol charter
ils ont l'impression que finalement on
vit pas dans le même monde et c'est
aussi le symbole de l'arrogance du
pouvoir vis-à-vis des français parce que
et leur fils ne s'impose pas lui même
c'est qu'ils imposent aux autres on a
voté une loi de moralisation de la vie
politique
on a encadré les frais des députés et
force est de constater que ce que l'on
impose aux députés on n'impose pas
forcément miss au premier ministre je
trouve que c'est regrettable et surtout
les conditions et la manière dont ça
s'est fait avec 60 personnes qui ont
changé d'avion en cours de route voilà
il changeait de l'avion puisqu'en fait
ils sont allés avec un avion de l'état
de lever que le dernier à tokyo et c'est
à ce moment là qu'ils sont montés dans
l'avion
louez renaud girard êtes vous choqué par
tout cela
j'avais compris que
pour une raison qui m'échappe l'avion
militaire effectivement est arrivé vide
à roissy deux heures après l'avion qui
ont été loués qui est arrivé donc à
paris mais pour permettre au premier
ministre d'assister un conseil de
défendre autre chose importante parce
que président la république lui-même
partait en voyage juste après non cette
voie là on a les rives d'utiliser deux
langues il fallait que nation est la
cause du talent donc ça c'était sans
doute ne peut être une raison suffisante
pour faire cette dépense se dépense
importante je crois pas affectivement
d'abord je crois pas que les douars
philippe et c'est là jadallah
prémunissent extrêmement chargé c'est
pas lui qui s'occupe de ces de ces
détails de deux logiques il n'a pas le
temps et c'est un peu normal c'est pas
son boulot derrière de voilà le et est
donc je suis d'accord qu'il faut pas
faire dans le populisme
ceci dit c'est vrai il ya un problème
est un problème en france général de
train de vie l'état et aussi de l'autre
jour je suivais en scout est une sorte
de deux voitures c6 qui a brûlé un feu
rouge avec une sonnerie deuxième la
police j'y tiens je savais pas que le
commissaire de police avaient des
cécités des grandes citroën comme ça et
il sait il s'est arrêté devant le
restaurant lasserre et d'été 12h30 et en
est sorti un ancien premier ministre
pour aller déjeuner vous dépêtre tard
visiblement elle qui s'était permis de
brûler le feu rouge
et là je me suis arrêté en scooter et
jeudis vous épate s'étalent les flics
sont venus vers moi
monsieur je dis je suis renaud girard du
figaro et vous allez bientôt entendre
parler de moi cédé à calmer toutes ses
gammes et tout s'est donc il ya
effectivement un problème pas en
l'espèce parce que il faut il faut voir
eagle l'a très bien dit les jeux c'est
bon c'est pas qui exactement pays
peut-être que les hommes d'affaires payé
leur billet je n'en sais rien et puis il
y avait ce procès de défense du moment
l'avion militaire ne pouvait pas faire
la connexion attend donc je ne veux pas
juger en espèces mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya un problème et c'est vrai aussi que
c'est un peu dommage que les ministres
et des premiers ministres et tout cet
appareil et que de temps en temps ils ne
prennent pas le métro pour voir comment
ça se passe où le train normalement
pouvoir ils ne prennent que dès que les
deux avions privés pour pourvoir par mme
way pour pouvoir le phénomène des
retards a laissé la vie alors que dans
les autres pays en suède ou même en
suisse
c'est en suisse le président de la
confédération et prend sa petite
volkswagen de chez lui et est en attente
en otage et en allemagne sap arena au
bureau alors après s'il a inauguré un
bâtiment public live avoir peut-être que
même des motards etc
mais il ya effectivement c'est vrai nos
auditeurs le dise il ya une déconnexion
et c'est dommage moi je trouve que c'est
bien
il faudrait que une fois par semaine une
fois tous les dix jours sans dire parce
que ce qui protège les gens c'est bien
tous les policiers c'est l'anonymat
mais que voilà qui prennent le métro 8
août a fait qu'ils prennent le métro une
fois comme ça pour elle à roissy prendre
le métro c'est utile c'est ce qu'on
insiste le message est passé mais a dit
du figaro.fr nous a rejoints mais rien
ne vous êtes plongés dans les réseaux
sociaux est ce que c'est aussi critique
que les internautes qui nous envoient
leurs réactions en direct dans la même
veine sur twitter c'était un des sujets
les plus commentés
aujourd'hui donc avec le hashtag edouard
philippe mais aussi avec le mot-clé
tokyo paris plus de 30 mille tweets et
sur nos articles on a plus de 3000
commentaire donc effectivement les gens
sont assez choqué énervé en fait ce qui
ce qui les énerve surtout c'est le fait
qu'ils aient dit j'assume ça c'est
quelque chose qu'ils ne passent pas du
tout on a notamment gibus 15 qui nous
disent qu'ils nous dit le confort a bon
dos quand ce sont les autres qui paient
pendant des années j'ai fait les 22
heures de vol entre paris et haïti avec
escale à los angles
si je me suis coutumier au confort des
avions air france sans être en classe
affaires du temps du ps il est arrivé
que certains disent ce n'est pas cher
c'est l'état qui paye donc rien ne
change
or l'état c'est nous cherchez l'erreur
on à la mouche qui nous dit
théoriquement quand on dit j'assume
on en tire les conclusions mais là non
le fait d'assumer et suffisants c'est
devenu le moyen de défense des
politiques qui lorsqu'ils sont pris en
flagrant délit de mauvaise gestion ou
mauvaises décisions nous abreuve d'un
j'assume avant de passer à un autre
sujet le j'assume n'étant suivies
d'aucun acte réparateur
c'est tristement lamentable donc ça
c'est à peu près ce qui ressort dans les
commentaires du figaro sur twitter
pareil on a énormément de personnes qui
critiquent
on a notamment en gérant votre foi qui
nous dit 350000 euros tarif du tokyo
paris et 60 colobes pour edouard
philippe et 60 collaborateurs
quand l'ex premier ministre françois
fillon rentrer seul un week-end dans la
sarthe à 250 km le falcon le falcon de
la république coûtait 27000 euros au
tarif fillon tokyo paris coûterait 10
millions d'euros eric naulleau qui nous
dit tokyo paris pour edouard philippe
à ce prix là ce n'est plus un vol c'est
du vol on à vincent castella qui nous
dit cher edouard philippe
donc là il lui adresse une petite lettre
avec une jolie image que vous pouvez
voir à l'écran
trois cent cinquante mille euros pour
son vol tokyo paris cela représente 25
ans tu fixes et sans temps de course
pour une famille quatre personnes ça
fait aussi sur l'image 350 pile de 10
billets de 100 euros pour ça pour dire
que ça en fera vivre des gens adorent
philippe non marcelino qui nous dit
quand tu apprends le même jour que les
impôts augmenteront de 4 5 milliards
d'euros et que le et que le mini premier
ministe pardon j'ai eu un bug lourd un
avion a350 1000 euros pourra plus de
confort et gagné 2 euros sur un tokyo
paris les sacrifices toujours les mêmes
et enfin le compte twitter les répliques
qui nous dit enfin qui rappelle un
ancien tweet de thomas porcher qui
disait le même odeur philippe justifier
sa politique de rigueur en disant je
souhaiterais que les français mesurent
l'ampleur de ce dérapage nous n'avons
pas le droit de faire cela nos enfants
il ne revient pas de payer cette note
merci steve annoncé des patrons
qu'est-ce qui a balancé l'info c'est une
info afp
après qui est balancé j'aimerais juste
je posais une question c'est pourquoi
est ce qu'on parle de cela qui est
responsable c'est y soit pourquoi ça n'a
pas un thé ou un léger avons pour qu'il
puisse revenir sans qu'on en parle
ils sont partis on parle pas du prix du
allez on parle du puits du retour
pourquoi on parle de ça qui a fait la
bêtise de ne pas organiser un retour en
bonne et due forme
parce qu'il savait qu'il y avait un
conseil 2010 d'euros ce train il paye
même c'était annulé ou ont poussé à deux
jours plus tard donc qui était
responsable de tout cela c'est de la
mauvaise gestion et je reviens ce que je
disais tout à l'heure ça a écorné
l'image et du gouvernement et tu le
portes également des lois fille mais à
mon avis le chef de cabinet du premier
ministre a hélas à closer un peu
difficile
dionne c'est une remarque mais c'est il
ya quand même les avions sont maudits
dans la république parce qu'il ya eu
alain joyandet ya eu françois fillon il
ya on a une ribambelle et je pense que
l'avion incarne quelque chose d'un peu
encore dans un dans un état d'esprit un
peu de ses pas de quelque chose de
luxueux et puis et puis en effet ces
montants sont astronomiques en plus la
fin la pollution que il est maître
william hill polémique possible autour
de l'avion je pense qu'il ferait mieux
d'aller à pied sous la colonne y aller
en train est la raison devrait y
réfléchir et le fait que s'ils voulaient
chaque fois qu'un responsable public
pour des déplacements dangereux
professionnelle prend un avion avec par
exemple la classe affaires comme c'est
arrivé à jean luc mélenchon l'année
dernière immédiatement sa déjà une
polémique je suis désolé c'est vraiment
la démocratie du ressentiment ctrc c'est
une des possibilités de la démocratie
qui est de laisser se développer leur
sentiment c'est absurde en plus encore
une fois ce n'est pas pour des vacances
privées étaient visés par des sections
professionnelles ces petits bouts
l'économie mais c'est assez flou des ans
en un on a cherché la subtile peut-être
susceptibilités ya des gens avec cette
histoire et on n'en est pas du renom et
on aurait pu très bien vite et qu'on en
parlait il va finalement quelqu'un avait
une bêtise on en parle
et voilà surtout que
paradoxe accessoirement fait percuter
cette information avec des augmentations
d'impôts qui arrive on a parlé de la csg
notamment alors que cette transition a
été un peu laborieuse mais tant pis je
l'assumé aux états unis là bas au moins
on baise massivement les impôts
joyeux noël a dit donald trump à ses
concitoyens écoutez le titre home and
tax reform
bon alors rappel du contexte donc une
réforme fiscale assez ambitieuse du
président trump qui a été voté par le
sénat renaud girard on nous a répété
pendant des mois que ce président était
au bord de la destitution qui n'avait
pas de majorité que ça allait forcément
être une catastrophe
il se porte plutôt bien pour un grand
blessé oui puis la une
une loi là qui est arrivé à passer donc
une voie très importante puisque la
réduit je crois l'impôt sur les sociétés
de 38 ou 2 39% à 21 ou 22 donc c'est une
21 donc c'est une baisse considérable
est-ce que ça va créer des jobs
la dernière baisse aussi brutale
d'impôts qu'on avait eues avait marché
c'était avec donald reggane ronald
reagan s'était donc au début des années
80 et ça avait marché savait créer
beaucoup d'emplois aux états unis ça a
été un choc salutaire est ce que cela va
marcher de l'asean que la seule question
qu'on peut se poser c'est est-ce que les
américains vont ou non remboursé leur
dette qui est de 20 trillions de deux là
et je ne sais pas comment il va essayer
de ramener un petit peu ce déficit
budgétaire est-ce qu'ils vont introduire
ou non la tva partout aux états unis on
n'en sait rien mais c'est sûr que je ne
vois pas et je l'avais je crois déjà dit
dans ce cadre je ne vois pas un
empêchement c'est à dire une destitution
parlementaire de donald trump
il a su faire des concessions qu'il
fallait notamment à l'égard d' les
restes et du renégat delà de la russie
puisqu'il est accusé je pense en sont
elles font demande est une sorte d'agent
russie la d amitié pour là aussi je ne
pense pas qu'une trame soit un agent
russe bon et je pense pas que c'est la
rèze que l'intervention de la russie a
créé l'élection de trump aux états unis
je pense qu'il harrington a perdu pour
des raisons qu'on peut expliquer ici
mais il envoie là vous avez vu que ces
ralliés à la fois l'électorat juge new
yorkais et les républicains évangélique
avec la faire de l'art de transfert de
l'ambassade de tel aviv à jérusalem est
donc effectivement intuitivement etc
trump dans son de son propre intérêt
j'ai bien les choses est-ce qu'ils
gèrent bien est-ce qu'il est le vide le
leader du monde est ce qu'il y ait ce
qui gère bien des affaires du monde
de notre point de vue de français je
dirais non parce que il faut dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont il y à un
réchauffement climatique
il y à un réchauffement climatique il
est en grande partie de factures
humaines et le fait que les états unis
refusent de faire quoi que ce soit là
dessus et un problème est donc un
problème pour nous français entre autres
mais de son point de vue à lui il il
il gère pas mal effectivement son rôle
et s'acquiert de présidence peut-être
d'abord effectivement une victoire de
politique intérieure est ce qu'elle fait
changer le climat autour de trump
écoutez le
l'euphorie de paul ryan c'est le
président de la chambre des
représentants
philippe c'est un tournant cette cette
loi dans le mandat de l'autre il fallait
quand même une bonne nouvelle pour dans
le championnat n'a pas eu beaucoup ces
derniers temps donc pour lui bon c'est
un bon cadeau de noël au ces on sait pas
combien y perd en lui même quand même
sur la fortune qu'ils en pensent qu'il a
jamais fait de déclarations d'impôts au
personnel je suis assez la public mais
on dirait qu ubs qui comme un c'est
scandaleux l'on semble donc à une pose
plusieurs questions il a une victoire
c'est indéniable deuxième chose est ce
que ça va porter des fruits c'est un
pari un ace que la réduction des impôts
ça coûte cher
est ce que les sociétés équipe qui
commises des impôts des 35 38 % jusqu'à
26 au ponton vont créer des emplois pour
recréer de la richesse aux états unis
qui va prendre place pour payer l'argent
que l'état va perdre est avec les
réductions d'un peuple
ce n'est pas gagné d'avancé donc ça
c'est un pari sur le long terme
est-ce que les gens pauvres vont être
plus riches c'est parce que non plus
parce que la baisse si j'ai bien compris
d un peu et dégressif par rapport à
l'argent qu'on gagne donc les plus
pauvres vont avoir
les moindres de baisses d'impôts et les
plus riches font avec les gens qui
gagnent le plus
donc tout cela au son papier ça a l'air
très bien
so long sur le compte il faut que ça
marche je sais pas convaincu que ça
portera des fruits aussi rapidement que
dans notre ve et sur le fait qu'ils
soient sur le point d'être destitué
quand même sa part est une année
extrêmement bien pour lui avec tous les
déboires avec la russie il est pas du
tout sortis de l'auberge avec cela avec
la virginie qu'il a perdu aux démocrates
avec les démocrates qu'ils se ressoudent
entre ceux qui ont soutenu éric hinton
ceux qui ont soutenu ben ali sont deux
qui reviennent ensemble pour faire front
commun contre contre dans le trompe avec
les avec tout ce qu'il a eue c'était
unis de problèmes créés par la sphère
hervé wine steen qui ont retombées sont
là aussi cela il fallait quand même que
il a des problèmes donc et plus je me
dis les plus pauvres aux états unis ceux
qui ont profité de bam à quai qui risque
de ne plus la voir un jour ça aussi
c'est un problème pour les plus pauvres
qui sont de 7 cette réforme je pense pas
gagnant et vous êtes là encore inviter à
vous prononcer sur twitter dans notre
pâtit la bonne politique fiscale c'est
sûr hashtag figaro life hashtag point de
vue dionne de mon jeu mais c'est amusant
c'est le président ça fait un an que
tout le monde à la fois est dans le déni
ou et dans le tout sur ces menaces de 10
pitchouns et c est en fait il tient il
est très déterminé et ce plan là de
réforme fiscale est considérable comme
vous le disiez très bien et on a dit il
il possible que l'irlande grâce à son
plan infrastructures ces grands travaux
dont il avait parlé beaucoup pendant sa
campagne et que peut-être qui termine
son mandat avec un bilan à la roosevelt
faget on est vraiment en voit on est
face à un homme dont on tout on a
critiqué l'outrance et la est un peu le
caractère ingérable et bien dans le fond
cette détermination à moi elle me
stupéfie jeudi il a réussi parce que
depuis riga donc depuis trente ans et
c'est en 86 voix n'a pas été fait donc à
mon avis cette réforme
moi elle m'a intrigué je me questionne
sur le trump d'après ce genre de succès
parce qu'en fait ce n'est pas son
premier succès parce que pour lui tout
ce qui te suit et tout ce qu'il fait est
un succès c'est un homme qui n'a aucune
espèce de capacité de retour critique
sur lui-même ça se voit
davance tout le temps comme un bulldozer
et panzer trump fait tout le temps le
coup d'après pour disney pour surtout
que les critiques ne s'appesantissent
pas trop sur les échecs d'avant donc en
fait pour lui c'est un des énièmes
succès mais celui là en plus il est
consacré objectivement par une opinion
publique à un congrès qui est attaquée
docile donc à mon avis on va plus du
tout le même trente mille pattes
maintenant les défilés d'affaires qui
sont ici je viens pas que notre congrès
de style parce que sur d'autres
questions parole sur la russie le
congrès s'est monté tout à fait une
critique rebelles
le concret derrière n'est jamais docile
aux états unis et c'est pas une chambre
d'enregistrement le congrès c'est
vraiment un pouvoir et derrière les des
mots clés les membres des partis ont la
liberté de voter comme ils le veulent
ils suivent pas forcément la discipline
du parti
mais là en l'occurrence le congrès et le
président ont avancé ensemble et vous
avez vu ce ce chef de la chambre des
représentants qui est le monsieur ryan
qui a été quelquefois critique de du
président trump ils sont ensemble et
c'est effectivement c'est une vraie
victoire qui rappelle qui rappelle le
moment de trump qui était en 1980 après
81 89 andrianavalona reagan rares alexis
lacroix et vous vous aussi enthousiaste
devant l'initiative du président entre
je suis pas du tout enthousiaste parce
qu'en plus c'est terrible ce type de la
dérégulation économique c'est pas
forcément ma tasse de thé vous êtes
contre la baisse des impôts par contre
la baisse des impôts mais disons-le
avait le droit
ça ne me paraissait pas être la mesure
la plus cardinal est la plus prometteuse
du programme de trump mais force est de
reconnaître comme vous d'ailleurs que
vous voulez de le faire comme une lionne
viens viens de faire que la sur ce plan
là il marque un point et c'est
l'occasion de la plèbe panzer fremm
c'est pas faux il ya un côté droit dans
ses bottes comme on dit dans le
commentaire politique français si vous
laissez quelqu'un qui ne se laisse pas
impressionner par la mauvaise opinion
qu'ils propagent autour de lui et c'est
probablement finalement sur la durée
peut-être sa force et dire que c'est un
barbie a dégoté barbare que c'est
incontestable d'ailleurs la presse
française les dénonce à mon avis
d'ailleurs à juste titre le plus souvent
mais le paradoxe c'est que ça fait sans
doute sa force et donc panzer trump se
fiche pas mal de ce que l'opinion
internationale peut penser de lui et je
suis d'accord
il y à une des rires en ce sens il ya
une des réalisations d'une partie des
critiques émises par les européens et
notamment on va dire par les européens
politiquement correct en réalité ça ne
correspond pas là comment dire à la
solidité du socle sociologique sur
lequel est appuyé aujourd'hui de phrases
néanmoins n'oublions pas ce qu'on dit
d'émission en émission
la semaine dernière on évoquait d'autres
revers de donald trump est donc tout ça
est à double tranchant
il ya une solidité de l'assise
sociologique mais il ya aussi quand même
une fragilité politique qu'à mon avis
cette réduction de baisses d'impôts
reuze ne va pas complètement contrarié
et je ne serais pas étonné moi en ce qui
me concerne qu'à la fin de sa présidence
il se retrouve littéralement en short je
nie pas une pitcher mais empêchés d'agir
eh bien vous reviendrait à cheikh
alexeeva quoi pour nous parler de ça
quand il aura changé de tenue et
effectivement si on le retrouve en short
revenons en france si vous le voulez
bien pour parler des du dossier des
migrants
le premier ministre prépare avec l'aide
de gérard collomb le ministre de
l'intérieur à projet de loi sur le droit
d'asile et aussi sur le le contrôle et
la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine
ce concept ce projet semble indiquer
qu'on va vers un durcissement
ça provoque des états d'âme peut-être un
début de fronde on va en parler
chez les députés de la république en
marche écoutez sonia crime y est les
députés de ce parti député de la manche
un traitement du séjour irrégulier en
france est devenue une angoisse pour les
étrangers pour les associations dont on
salue tous ici le travail pour les
forces de police pour les préfectures et
les avocats pourriez vous monsieur le
ministre à nous détailler les équilibres
politiques de votre réforme une réforme
sont posture et son préjugé une réforme
juste et humaine à laquelle nous et des
images à déplacer on agira ce ton rompt
avec le espèce de d'unanimisme qui était
jusque là de mise c'est la république en
marche
oui mais c'est vraiment c'est un propos
qu'auraient pu
tenir un député mélenchonistes c'est à
dire qu'en fait on a l'impression que
dans sa campagne
macron qui voulait à la fois de gauche
et de droite n'existe plus il n'a pas
pris de positions extrêmement ferme sur
sur l'immigration alors certes il a dit
qu'il n'allait pas remettre en cause le
regroupement familial c'est cette
décision qui a été prise par décret
simple par chirac en 1975 il a dit qu'
il a dit quand même dans sa campagne
qu'il ferait les reconduites à la
frontière parce que le problème c'est
que même beau qu'il ya beaucoup
d'expulsions évidemment des illégaux des
gens qui sont venus sans passer par les
procédures français sur le territoire
français et qui ne sont en fait jamais
expulsé tellement il ya de recours en
fait des recours en justice cette année
très difficile en fait d'expulser
quelqu'un du territoire du territoire
français alors il sait pas il sait pas
vraiment prononcé et donc il c'est un
peu normal que dans son que dans son
soutien c'est à dire sa base
parlementaire
eh bien il ya des gens qui sont plus
plus propres aux migrants alors ces gens
qui sont très trop migrants ne nous
disent pas comment ils vont les loger
dise pas que dans un pays où il ya des
portions de chômage c'est vouloir
trouver du travail nous disent pas
comment ils vont les éduquer et nous et
ne nous explique pas si c'est est ce que
c'est une bonne idée que l'europe soit
un appel d'air comme ça à cause des
aides sociales un appel d'air qui vide
les populations et l'ouest africain de
ces populations les plus les plus fortes
parce qu'en fait pour cette aventure de
la migration c'est quand même une
aventure où il faut quand même être être
entreprenant et être physiquement fort
donc les les pros immigrationniste
deneault qu'une réponse là dessus mais
bon voilà il ya en france des d
immigration liste ils sont assez
nombreux ils sont pas seulement chez
mélenchon et il a visiblement blessé et
il serait temps effectivement que mâcon
peut-être qu'il n'a pas vraiment fait
dans la campagne disent exactement ce
qu'il en est de la politique qu'ils
proposent pour le pays parce que alexis
lacroix hier il ya pas mal députés dans
marche qui qui sont d'anciens élus
socialistes
et là pour le coup cette espèce de
d'offensive contre l'immigration
clandestine
je rappelle que le ministre l'intérieur
a annoncé qu'il allait créer des unités
pour aller voir dans les hôtels sociaux
et vérifier que les immigrés qui sont là
ont bien droit d'être là tout ça c'est
quand même un tournant droitier pour
vous le dirai de la sorte je pense que
c'est la reconstitution d'un
affrontement qui a eu lieu pendant l'ère
hollande entre deux gauches
renault n'a pas tort sur le constat mais
c'est pas tellement là je ne crois pas
que pour le coup comme renault que ce
soit par défaut d'explicitation de la
part de macron c'est simplement qu'à
l'intérieur aujourd'hui de sa majorité
il y à vous avez raison guillot beaucoup
de parlementaires qui ont fait leurs
armes dans la bon on va dire dans la
mouvance socialiste au sens large
mais ce qui la fracture aujourd'hui
c'est pas tellement le retour du droit
de gauche c'est le retour d'une guerre à
l'intérieur des gauches qui avait existé
souvenons nous lorsque manuel valls
assumait une position au fond assez
proche de celle de colomb aujourd'hui et
qu'il se retrouvait avec hollande face à
des frondeurs qui eux effectivement et
est authentiquement comme le dit renaud
des immigrationniste à mon avis c'est
une fracture à l'intérieur d'une partie
de la gauche macro nien qui se scinde en
fait en deux entre des gens qui sont
plutôt sur une conception république
hanister sécuritaire autrement dit
responsable sur les questions
d'immigration et seyante doser la
fermeté l'humanité c'est toujours
compliqué on peut toujours trouver à
redire
et je crois d'ailleurs que le comment
dire la grandeur des démocraties c'est
qu'on puisse trouver à redire qu on
puisse continuer à critiquer ce que fait
colons même si c'est pas si mal et de
l'autre côté des gens qui incarnent sept
députés dont vous venez de passer le
message qu'ils sont
sont beaucoup plus sur une radicalité
gauchistes sur le plan culturel qui
rejoint probablement les positions de la
france insoumise en cette matière sert
des gens qui sont plutôt dans la morale
de conviction pour parler comme weber
s'inclinent 5 qui ne s'intéresse pas aux
effets pratiques des discours qu'il
prononce qu'il prêche mais justement
c'est assez intéressant parce que ça
veut ça veut dire aussi c'est si c'est
une désillusion si vous les fondatrices
du maquereau nisme qui à mon avis est en
train de s'évaporer la l'illusion de
fondatrice du maquereau nice elle à sa
grandeur c'est le sait le déplacement du
droit de gauche et des confrontations
traditionnelle et ben là paf sur ce
sujet là qui est tellement sensible et
qu'au fond tellement passionnant et tout
le monde se regarde graphie très
clairement
vous avez une gauche sociale démocrate
responsable vous avez une extrême gauche
immigrationniste et vous avez une droite
ultra sécuritaire en gros il ya trois
familles et elles apparaissent en pleine
lumière
j'allais dire à l'insu de la macro dis
donc c'est la première facture politique
d'une campagne open bars en fête
macron a fait une campagne dure et
fractures oui facturé fracture est donc
en fait c'est une à mon avis ce qui se
passe en ce moment sur ce sujet là et
dont personne ne s'est emparé depuis 30
ans parce que nicolas sarkozy en 2007
avait tenté puis avait enfoui une
tentative parce que en fait c'est un
sujet brûlant il ya tout là l'idéologie
très forte qui a autour de l'accueil de
la france pays d'accueil terre d'asile
france des libertés france de la
démocratie fin france qui doit faire
c'est donner asile à ceux qui sont les
plus vulnérables dans le monde et pour
défendre et puis il ya l'autre côté
pragmatique mais en même temps l'autre
côté pragmatique qui est celui de
évidemment comme vous disiez 10% de
chômage et impossibilité parfois de les
intégrer à la vitesse à laquelle on
pourrait le faire mais je trouve que
finalement moi ce qui m'a matrix et
comment ce président n'a pas peur de
s'emparer de sujets aussi qu'à ce
comment dire poliment casse popularité
bravo merci sens parce que c'est
vraiment un sujet qui va à mon avis
déterminé par mal les débats de tout
premier trimestre prochain et je croyais
et je crois que guillon a parfaitement
raison bio mais on sous-estimé
encore un peu dans la dans le jour le
jour à jour
enfin comment dire la routine du
commentaire politique le fait que ça va
être à mon avis la deuxième grande
question civilisationnel de l'année il
ya eu en gros la sphère charlie
mediapart c'est à dire la question de
l'islamisme de la laïcité à l'automne et
pendant l'hiver est probablement le
printemps ce sera la question migratoire
qui va s'inviter et qui va si j'ose dire
rv hectos risée l'ensemble du débat
politique merci m
saluant les nombreux internautes qui
envoient leurs commentaires notamment le
droitiste qui salue la qualité de cette
émission c'est un homme de goût et les
unes qui nous disent en être de gauche
et de droite un peu de bon sens devrait
mener le gouvernement
philip earl allait-il à quoi nous dit
après l'islam c'est l'immigration qui
vient structurer le débat
tout ça n'est pas très nouveau
finalement on en revient au réel pour
moi c'est tout un signe que les partis
politiques sont assez paumé sur le
problème de migration ne savent pas
comment on fait pour le gérer vous avez
toutes les extrémités ce qui veut
absolument pas ce qu'ils veulent inviter
tout le monde ceux qui essayent de faire
avec et lyon qui sont là des gens donc
quelle politique est ce qu'il faut mais
les personnes ne s'aimaient mais
maintenant qu il y en a pas parlé de la
seule chose que manioc mâcon a dit qu'il
n'a pas fait et c'est de menacer lacombe
autant d'aveux de mettre la frontière du
côté de calais du côté d'eux après
brique site bidon et une mère quand je
serai élu c'est ce que je veux mais il
en est rien parce que ça sans desservir
la france au long terme et le moment
bouge affrontait on le met à deux ça
sera un appel d'air pour tous les
migrants qui viennent de partout pour
revenir à calais pour des sons qu'on
plus facile pour les en angleterre donc
c'est pas la réponse à la question pour
moi la réponse à la question c'est même
pas un problème français c'est un
problème européen est temps que l'europe
n'a pas pris en main ce problème avec
ses propres frontières les frontières
schengen
parce que quoi qu'on fasse on fonce donc
reconduit à la frontière on arrête les
migrants ils vont continuer de venir
parce qu'il a pas de frontières donc
comment voulez-vous régler son problème
quand on peut pas les bloquer à
l'extérieur de la france c'est pas
possible
donc il faut quand même trouver une
solution européenne et tant qu'on n'a
pas retrouvé ben ça n'avancera pas seule
chose qui peut être positif c'est
qu'avec la fin des guerres en syrie en
irak
peut-être qu'on trouvera une solution
pour le problème libyen
et
la vague d'immigrants on va peut-être
baissé mais en attendant aujourd'hui
tous les migrants viennent de pays qui
sont pas en guerre qui m'aimera
tellement donc c'est cette voie guérilla
qui viennent le cloud oui je pense que
sarko est dans la vie au français arnaud
gérard colline mais ce biais nous dit
pourquoi ne pas faire un référendum sur
cette question
mais pour quelques questions à la ici on
dit quoi vous ne voulez pas directement
6 6 2 présent la république se sentait
pas suffisamment ce qui peut prendre des
décisions extrêmement extrêmement dur
par exemple mettre la fin au mouvement
familial par exemple 10 ans nathan que
les immigrés qui sont ici ne sont pas
bien a t on va suspendre le regroupement
familial et qui pense qu'il a besoin
d'un support populaire il peut utiliser
les paluds clé voilà un grand voilà le
mais je pense que vous avez raison je
pense que c'est un sujet européen
l'europe a fait ce chemin guerre sans
prendre les mesures pour effectivement
tu essaies oui voilà c'était pas même
chose pour empêcher
négation et s'ils voulaient l'europe
fonctionne comme un appel d'air
extraordinaire et l'europe est dans une
position tout à fait différent du japon
ou de spa des pays riches ou des états
unis qui eux effectivement parviennent
tout à fait avoir
l'immigration est qu'ils veulent à part
un peu les états unis par l'immigration
mexicaine mais aujourd'hui il ya un
appel d'air considérable avec avec des
avec des trafics c'est vous dire il ya
une industrie des barbaresques avec avec
les problèmes d' esclavage de droit y
est le cas il ya un industrie dans le
sahel de gangsters en fait en salaires
qui profite parce qu'en fait dans
l'ouest africain les familles
maintenance se cotise réveillait
j'approuvais dans les villages pour
trouver 3000 euros pour financer pas
sérieuse et évidemment seul immigré qui
sera arrivé en europe et qui pourra
toucher les aides sociales ensuite doit
évidemment reverser la moitié de ce qui
touche à aux familles qui se sont
cotisés avec les problèmes de logement
insalubre enfin pas tous les problèmes
qu'on a avec une immigration choisie et
disent que ce café macron la cndh issus
de dissuasion et migratoires là
maintenant de montrer qu'il est co l'axé
petite révolution mais qu'on va plus
être superficiel oui je vais je pense je
pense comme le disait très bien que
c'est une question effectivement
européenne parce que si les gens
puissent aller peuvent arriver en italie
comment vous allez ensuite mais les
blocs ses collègues ont ils veulent
venir chez nous vont mais il veut même
pas rester au fond ça dépend des cas les
quelques minutes qui nous reste pour
parler d'une affaire qui à mon avis
moins anecdotique qu'il y paraît charlie
hebdo en la personne de son rédacteur en
chef rice a soutient cette semaine un
animateur un ex-animateur devrais je
dire de france télévisions qui a été
renvoyé de cette chaîne
alors je vous refais juste les épisodes
précédents très vite nous sommes le 30
novembre dernier
un animateur qui s'appelle texte qui
anime l'émission
les z'amours sur france 2 est invité sur
une autre chaîne c8 et là il sort une
blague on va dire plus qu'approximative
mais je vous propose de la réécouter ce
sujet super sensible je l'attend
les gars vous savez ce qu'on dit à une
femme qui a déjà les deux yeux au beurre
noir allait tirer de cela on le dit plus
rien on vient des jeunes m'expliquer
deux fois alors à la suite de cette
blague
la secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'égalité hommes-femmes marne et ya pas
saisi le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel et je le disais tech c'est
donc renvoyés de france 2 après des
années de collaboration qu'est ce que
dit riis le patron de charlie hebdo il
dit ben on ne peut plus rire de rien il
ya une vague autoritariste on est envahi
par les corbeaux par les délateurs et
lui dit il faut soutenir l'humour même
s'il est de mauvais goût
est-ce que vous avez un point de vue sur
ce sujet idiote de montjoux oui je
d'abord oui la blague elle n'était connu
cette blague je pense que c'est pas lui
qui l'a inventé tout de suite donc et en
plus il n'est pas sur france télévisions
donc je trouve que le leur envoyer un
présentateur qui depuis 17 ans anime une
émission qui en plus est une émission
d'égalité homme femme c'est comme
tournez manège oui il ya toujours un avc
des couples qui doivent se dire quel a
été le jour où je t'ai pas pardonné
cetera donc c'est vraiment l'émission la
plus légère et sans aucun enjeu
et quand vous la regardez ce que j'ai
fait cet après midi pour la première
fois on voit que il est toujours dans la
petite phrase dans le petit truc
d'humour
il ya un côté chez lui qui est un peu
comme ça dans ce sens est dans cette
énergie là de l'instant de vouloir être
le bon camarade mais par ailleurs je
trouve que depuis cet événement on voit
que depuis 17 ans il est dans cette sur
cette chaîne est que depuis quelques
années visiblement cette chaîne veut se
débarrasser de lui et qu'il ya eu
plusieurs témoignages dans ce sens
qu'ils disaient qu'ils avaient cherché
un remplaçant à un moment donné pour
comme pour cette présenter cette
émission
donc je me demande si c'est pas un très
bon prétexte trouvé pour renvoyer
alors comme ça c'est pour la faire texte
mais surtout plein d'humour je dirais
que c'est un peu pénible même de
réécouter cette blague que je trouve pas
drôle du tout et je me dis voilà donc
tout est tellement subjectif et voilà
n'est pas drôle du tout mais on a le
droit on a le doigt on a le droit de 26
si elle n'est pas la console wii la
police de la force et agréable arrêté
par la police de la pensée c'est
insupportable si vous voulez aujourd'hui
maintenant on a new york aider des gens
qui font des pétitions pour empêcher un
tableau de balthus parce qu'ils
prétendent qu'il est pédophile face et
ses courses et complète mais c'est
devenu complètement fou cette prise de
la pensée en revanche la question qu'on
doit se poser c'est est ce que ce
monsieur que je ne connaissais pas texte
doit être payé avec nos impôts pour
faire une émission sur france 2 un
problème du service public c'est
effectivement je suis d'accord avec vous
sur une chaîne commerciale
bon écoute et une certaine vulgarité des
chaînes commerciales il peut très bien
effectivement faire ces grosses valser
grosse ces grosses vannes comme ça ça on
sent qu'on interdise la liberté
d'expression et liberté blague là en
revanche en revanche en revanche en
revanche il y a un problème dans
le service public le service public est
fait par les impôts et donc se doit une
qualité éducative ya longtemps qu on ya
renoncé
bah oui c'est tout à fait dommage et
donc je pense que macro a tout à fait le
diraison tout à fait raison de dire que
la qualité du service public en france
et je vais juste que je vais passer la
parole alexis lacroix mais non sans
avoir précisé que la blague en question
l ai fait l ai pas fait sur le service
de henin l'avait fait suite à celle
mitchell m'arrive d'aller au moins j'ai
finalement est-ce que le politiquement
correct est en train de tout étouffer
dans ce pays oui mais c'est un autre
sujet et je vais je pense que non je
veux redire en euros et non les blagues
lourdes non c'est fini non c'est un
autre sujet je pense que antoine
griezmann quand il se grime on pour
rendre dans leur rendre hommage aux
joueurs blacks et alpha sim
ça c'est le footballeur il est il et il
est victime d'un procès en sorcellerie
politiquement incorrect absolument rien
eu lieu les peaux noires pour l'élire
sont admirés mais je porter à méré voilà
mais je pense que rice que dont j'admire
par ailleurs les combats va un peu vite
en besogne en volant au secours de ce
monsieur qui est sans doute un humoriste
estimable que j'ai vu moi même à la télé
plusieurs fois et que là en l'occurrence
texte avait fait et c'est pas simplement
une blague lourd il avait fait si vous
voulez c'est une faute de goût c'est une
photo ou assez grave quand on sait par
ailleurs valencia pas ledit sur ça je
suis désolé à la raison qu'il y à une
impunité des violences
disons domestique très forte et dont de
nombreuses femmes sont encore les
victimes et donc je crois que sans faire
de dramatisation hystérique comme aime
le politiquement correct d'aujourd'hui
il était bon que d'une manière ou d'une
autre ils soient sanctionnés j'ignore
les circonstances où les arrière pensées
des personnes qui au sein de france
télévisions en en profiter pour
l'évacuer mais je pense en revanche que
voler au secours de textes comme s'il
s'agissait d'une sorte de nouveau
capitaine dreyfus c'est un peu ridicule
alors je vous propose de voter là encore
sur ce thème sur le hashtag figure en
live #primaires us que le soutien de ris
et a donc l'animateur tex est justifiée
bien vous êtes une grande majorité
effectivement a approuvé la position de
charlie hebdo
on va demander à philippe thorel son
avis là dessus mais je voudrais avant
vous donner un témoignage un petit point
de vue intéressant celui de vincent
trémolet de villers c'est le patron du
figaro vox
il se trouve que l'on découvre via une
en gros à un phénomène un processus qui
se répète chaque jour il ya une cible
qui dit une bêtise ou pas ou quelque
chose qui est considéré comme coupable
ou pas et il ya une meute numérique qui
se met en place et qui la poursuit et
qui la chasse avec un certain nombre de
pratiques et accompagne ça qui nous
viennent des pays anglo saxons qu'on
appelle le name and shame c'est à dire m
nommer la personne mais aussi alerté via
le compte twitter de son employeur son
employeur pour essayer de mettre sept
personnes en difficulté vis-à-vis de son
employeur et dans ceux de ce processus
il n'y a pas de défense
y a pas de dialogue il n'y a pas d'
écoute il n'y a pas d'étude du dossier
ce qui arrive dans la vie commune et
dans la conversation c'est à dire une
décence une retenue le fait que l'autre
est un visage qu'on fasse attention à la
wilaya plus tout ça et ça peut être
parfois effrayant alors vous êtes assez
partagés sur les réseaux sociaux parce
que il ya certains disent en distinguant
d'abord l'acte de griezmann en dix ans
lac de guiers 2 manon qui s'est grimé en
noir n'est pas raciste mais son acte
lait et on fait allusion à la blague
fait ce qui était une une
une coutume qui était qui n'est plus
d'usagé on peut sans doute s'en
féliciter en revanche pour texte là les
gens disent plutôt que sa blague n'est
pas drôle et que c'est assez grave mais
comme il s'est excusé il ne serait pas
justifié qu'il soit viré des amours
philip earl est ce que c'est anecdotique
ce dont on parle où çà çà çà montre une
espèce de de pression qui peut peut-être
être inquiétante pour la libre
expression
je trouve que c'est que ça fait une
pendant les mois le terme et il a fait
une connerie en racontant cette blague à
la télé ok il ya la libre parole enfance
s'il fomidable et je suis le premier la
première personne terre je pense le ton
mais je suis la première personne à part
essayent de protéger cela parce que
c'est quand même assez rare dans le
monde aujourd'hui et on est dans un
monde de plus en plus puritains où c'est
plus on pour difficile pour des ce qu'on
pense et j'ai grandi avec la bbc avec la
comédie britannique avec les monty
python aujourd'hui c'est fini tout ça
parce qu'elle a politiquement correct a
pointé des tués la comédie britannique
comme moi j'ai connu on est dans les 60
donc il il a fait une bêtise parce que
il aurait dû réfléchir avant de raconter
ses blagues au fait que vous avez très
bien dire une femme qui tue et les jours
et demi en france par son compagnon
donc on est dans une société de violence
pourquoi il n'a pas raconté cette blague
en disant un homme qui a deux yeux noirs
zoo et et personne n'aurait rien dit
donc là il a fait une bêtise
la réaction de ris ça il a raison de le
dire et turiaf 2 est tout à fait dans
son rôle
vu ce qu'ils arrivaient à ce journal de
dire quelqu'un peut raconter ce qu'il
veut et je protège cette personne je le
soutiens il a raison de dire cela et je
suis avec risque quand il dit cela mais
je pense que là la sanction de france
télévisions est quand même un peu l'eau
on aurait dû lui faire un bon ni nous de
te mettre un misérable à l'épreuve pour
un certain temps donc je soupçonne tout
à fait derrière caisse est une façon de
france de se débarrasser de quelqu'un
qui peut-être coûté un peu cher la
chaîne pour mettre quelqu'un à sa place
et ce sera le mois de la fin parce qu'on
est très en retard merci beaucoup à tous
les quatre pour ce que vous nous avez
dit c'était patience pour ça qu'on a
pris un peu plus de temps pour vous
écouter jusqu'au bout ce point de vue
c'est fini pour ce soir mais ça reprend
demain même heure même endroit merci